- Ahem, ay, yo, it's ya'
boy Jamal, a.k.a. DJ Sully.
We got some thin love right here
The homie, Grover,
what's happenin'?
- Wassup, Snap? Hey, they
don't want you to be a legend.
- Say what? Who don't
want you to be a legend?
- Well first off, Mark-ass
Coach Bundy. And sec--
- Free-ality check, you
jumpshot is minor key alert.
- Damn!
- More fan love,
here's my boy Milk.
- Wassup, ya'll?
Just wanna give shouts
to my side-boos, uh
Darkeisha, and uh, Deeballatti.
- Who dey ass?
I'm with yo'
pasty-ass 24/7-Eleven.
And I ain't never heard
of them vijiglets.
- Damn, Jamal, snap is for
the boos, not the news!
And yo' heavyset head keep
hoggin' the whole screen!
- See? They don't want you to be
Meaty Male Model Material,
so we gon' be Meaty
Male Model Material.
(laughs)
(Old Man laughs)
- I like that.
(Jamal cries in disgust
while others chuckle)
♪ LEGENDS